during the big show on Monday expect to  Carrie Underwood's am hun duet hey its  heartbeat yeah actually I don't know for  sure he'll supposed to tell you that or  not yeah that was easy and we love the  idea 2016's Best New Artist nominee  collaborating with 2007's Best New  Artist winner I hope that uh well for  one that I stay out of her way country's  hottest new star was giving back last  night performing with students at grammy  in the school's live by the way ladies  he's good with kids 63 31 and singled  who are you bringing as your date on  monday well my pants will be with me but  my manager Brad he'll be my my date for  the for the grandma shop